hallo mein name ist super und ich habe
auf meinem kanal schon schwoll face
quest 1 das habe ich schon gespielt dann
habe ich auch noch toll face quest 2
gespielt
worauf lasse ich mich hier immer ein und
heute spiele mit rolf ace cats 3 das
heißt wir klicken einfach mal auf play
und haben wieder so komischen spaß die
wir hier sehen wir die troller lisa
eingebildet wer kennt sie nicht wir
kriegen mal auf next und sehen die
troller lisa wurde wohl geklaut das
heißt wir gehen jetzt einfach mal aufs
tat mit solos fahren hier wurde keine
steuerung gesagt ich weiß nicht mit
welchen mit wie ich dass die ich dass
ich glaub ich muss das hat super
geklappt also ich weiß nicht genau was
ich machen soll wenn ich hier
draufklicken fährt er los und dann kommt
irgendwie aus dem nichts kommt dann von
der bombe das heißt auf die karre
draufklicken darf ich definitiv nicht
die kakteen die haben auch nichts zu
bedeuten ich weiß nicht was das hier
vorne ist das macht allerdings auch
nichts ich weiß auch nicht wo ich oder
ich muss dann
[Applaus]
und ich bin extra der bombe ausgewichen
also wenn man mit der maustaste auf das
auto drückt dann erfährt es einerseits
los wenn man allerdings wieder drauf
drückt dann bleibt er stehen das heißt
ich versuche jetzt diesmal vor der bühne
stehen zu bleiben übrigens trägt man
caps so mann mann mann mann setzt sie
sich nicht irgendwie so oder so nehme
man trägt diese und das trägt man auch
so das ist nämlich noch gibt das
eigentlich ist der wiener von de
hauptsache ich fragt wann gibt es das
eigentlich und ich mache eine einwendung
vom lukas shoppen sehr gut lukas gibt es
ab erster zwölfter
es bleibe ich jetzt allerdings stehen
wegen der bombe gebe jetzt wieder gas
und bleibe jetzt stehen vor
[Applaus]
[Musik]
warum ich gebe gas bleibe ich gebe gas
bleibe stehen die bombe schlägt jetzt
sehe ich auf die mine und die mine ist
jetzt glaube ich ausgeschaltet das heißt
falls dagegen macht keinen sinn also ich
fahre los ich bleibe bestehen dass die
bombe explodiert und jetzt kann ich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ihr könnt mir auch mal sagen dass das
spiel auf dragon reagiert beim nächsten
level müssen wir hier draufklicken das
heißt ich klicke drauf und wir sehen
natürlich level fällt weil so einfach
kann es nicht sein
ich weiß habe ich hier irgendwo anders
drauf klicken muss klicken
[Musik]
wie soll das funktionieren
ich würde sagen wir gehen so vor wie in
den letzten teilen auch ich probiere
meine möglichkeiten und sonst gucken
walkthrough nach also wir klicken
einfach mal auf walkthrough und sehen
dass wir okay da ich schaue mir das
jetzt machen
habs mann soll angeblich auf menü
klicken und dann kommt die vorne genau
das rollfeld
wie soll man denn da drauf kommen alter
das hier ist das nächste level wir haben
hier eine
nutzer können sie einfach mal anklicken
und sie möchte einen angebissenen apfel
dh wenn wir den apfel geben möchte sie
den natürlich nicht eigentlich würde ich
jetzt sagen dass ich den apfel einfach
selber mal essen muss damit er halt
angebissen ist aber wir schauen jetzt
mal vielleicht kann ich bei ihr hier
noch so ein bisschen woanders auflegen
sie möchte den apfel das heißt hier
oder wir müssen schnell sein als wir
klicken sie an dann hat er auch nicht
was ist wenn wir direkt auf den apfel
klicken dann will sie auch nicht mal
wieder so ein bisschen hier durch das
ganze fenster durch aber ich kann auch
nirgendwo anders drauf klicken außer
dass ich sie anklicken kann
sie kann ich sonst nirgendwo anklicken
und dass ich meinen apfel anklicken kann
scheiße
wie will jan angebissenen apfel das
heißt ich klicke er sie an jetzt weiß er
was sie will jetzt weist er den apfel an
und die jetzt lassen leid da wenn ich
das öfter machen soll weil ich werde so
gut darin wir müssen durch das labyrinth
zu der zielflagge die sache ist wenn ich
allerdings so dahin gehe dann ist es
wahrscheinlich nicht richtig der kleine
[ __ ]
die steuerung ist gerade investiert das
heißt ich muss mich quasi so ein
bisschen umdenken für diese quest also
ich muss jetzt so lang jetzt muss hier
unten wieder durch und jetzt so viel
[Musik]
nächstes level alter niemand kann was
gegen mich guck mal hier kommt die
panzer an werden wir die brücke die dort
vor wo ich habe gesehen dass ich auf dem
panzer auf jeden fall noch drauf drücken
kann das heißt nicht legal hier freunde
meine eigene pizza jetzt aber heute
erhältlich im laden könnt könnt ihr
kaufen
hey
das hier ist das nächste level ich weiß
ja dass hinten berge sind aber
wahrscheinlich sind eher wählen wenn er
eine taucherbrille auf hat also wie
klicken auf seine taucherbrille er
versucht zu atmen erst tot also ihm
können wir keine luft geben das heißt
wir versuchen es eventuell mal dass wir
die wellen vielleicht bisschen runter
packen da können wir allerdings auch
nichts anklicken wir können wirklich nur
ihn anklicken
das heißt ich tippe mal auf seinen
körper er atmet jetzt und atmet wieder
und ist tot
ich meine es gibt eigentlich überall
irgendwie was das dass man noch
anklicken kann ohne den typen vor sich
zu töten also ich denke einmal drauf da
passiert gar nichts ich weiß ich hier
irgendwie bei den start
[Musik]
wer kennt nicht aus dem ozean
martenstein hoch und das ganze wasser
fließt ab er wohl auf eine wand zu
gedrängt von einem typen das heißt wir
gehen auf die pistole und sind tot wenn
wir ihn anklicken steht eher auf wenn
wir jetzt schießen ist er immer noch tut
das wirklich noch restart er steht auf
setzt sich wieder hin was steht auf
jetzt ist er wieder tot
ich glaube das wird uns auch nicht zum
stil 2000 jahre später das nicht wahr
das ist für eine scheiße alter ich denke
nur an dieses dragon er schläft an einem
baum unter einem apfel wenn wir den
apfel runterfallen lassen
[Musik]
aber verloren ich weiß nicht ob ich an
dem baum noch etwas anders anklicken
kann weil den typen kann ich auf jeden
fall oder warte der beamte wackelt jetzt
da konnte ich den typen anklicken also
den typ kann ich nicht anklicken den
apfel kann ich auch nicht weg ich auch
nicht hin
ich weiß ich kann ich den baum irgendwie
verschieben oder so wenn okay hier kann
ich ihnen wie soll diese
ich dachte ich jetzt
da verloren weil auch wenn man die ganze
apfel auf die typen gefallen ist er
läuft auf die wand zu ich muss auf ihnen
draufklicken genau das läuft dann die
andere richtung und das level haben
jetzt auch geschafft das heißt klick auf
next level control 3 3 2 2 1 1 3 3 3 2 2
11 anrufen
level fällt wer kennt es nicht
ich bin nicht so dumm wie ich aussehe
das werden viele von euch jetzt
vielleicht gar nicht mehr wissen aber
früher habe ich beispielsweise nokia
handy und da musste man wenn man sms
verschicken wollte musste man immer
mehrmals auf eine zahl drauf drücken so
dass ein buchstabe kommt und da hier die
nummer durchgestrichenes und hier steht
control würde ich sagen ich drücke mal
auf das tier dann drücke ich dreimal auf
die sieben dann dreimal auf die sechs
dann ein 23 mal darauf und nochmal 12
[Musik]
warum fällt oder einfach tll anrufen ist
aber eigentlich nicht richtig haben eine
gießkanne eine verwelkte pflanze und
eine tödliche dies kann das heißt
natürlich erst mit normale gießkanne
gießen dieses ding nehmen wieder die
normale gießkanne gießen das ding nehmen
wieder eine normale gießkanne und sie
ist verwelkt das heißt es muss
wahrscheinlich eine andere kombination
seien normale gießkanne sie wächst
normale gießkanne sie wächst und die
todes gießkanne und sie ist perfekt
level complete complete
es gab schöne stimme wir stehen vor
einem fetten grinsen baum und haben eine
axt das heißt wir schlagen hin
so fallen wollen wir immer um
wir haben hier vorne einen ast und
können daran den ja da kommt doch jedes
kleine kind drauf ich mache ihnen den
kopf offen drehe an diesem rad und es
es passiert nichts die kanne hier vorne
mit dem öl oder was auch immer das ist
da passiert auch nichts und bei diesen
teilen ich meine
kannst du erstmal corp lebten hier also
ich habe mir gerade das wars ruhr
angeguckt und da wird gesagt dass man
hier draufklicken soll dann 1 2 3 4 5
[Musik]
das ja das ist dann dieser moment wenn
selbst das wort crew falsch ist
das war es jetzt aber hier auch vom
video meine damen und herren ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen wenn ich den
nächsten teil auch noch spielen soll ich
meine ich habe gerade teil 3 gespielt es
gibt glaube ich 15 teile oder irgendwie
so glasplatten leichter schreibt malt
rollin die kommentare und jetzt meine
damen und herren kommt dass auch das
wirklich jeder gewartet haben nämlich
das ende dieses video roll die austro
glas wasser ziehen
das war's jetzt hier vom video ihr könnt
jetzt hier meinen kanal abonnieren oder
hier unten mal einen job aus checken
hier findet ihr zwei andere videos und
wenn ich schon abonnent seid könnt ihr
auch die glocke klicken dann willkommen
die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]